good evening everyone when I was 14
years old I had the pleasure of working
with West duty in Terrence Malick's the
new world I will never forget the first
time that I met West on set yes I was a
bit intimidated to meet a man that I not
oh I grew up watching but a man who
could stop you dead in your tracks with
just one look and as I walked closer to
introduce myself to this larger than
life man
little did I know in that moment I met a
lifelong friend he's not only one of the
most secretly talented musicians I know
but one of the kindest most generous
humans on this planet
she is the type of person that in a room
full of strangers makes you feel like
you are seen and that you're not alone
and over the years Wes really has
revolutionized how indigenous people are
portrayed in cinema and he has inspired
and encouraged and really lifts a pack
showing us all what is possible and
through the spirit of wes is hard work
this award tonight symbolizes that yes
it can be done yes one person can make a
difference and yes we are still here
[Applause]